hello guys his silver at again with
another episode of the last play and
this time I'm going to make the Main
Street I think and some people get me a
suggestion to add some my college do
these buildings but I had no idea what
to do so I basically make the roof green
and it looks kind of cool in my opinion
I think I'll leave it like this it
immediately changed the whole layout of
the building they went in the hallway it
looks and it's a lot less bland and
boring now but anyway um I need to stop
running lis spinning around I'm going to
create some Main Street buildings so
that started time
there's no secret
mr. an
Oh break away
right
the answers lying here listen
hmm I've got quite some problems with a
spark at the moment because as you can
see and tell by the framerate moments
it's lagging a lot now as soon as I go
away from all these buildings in here
it's still kind of lagging and I've
checked I've checked the amount of space
that I still have left on my PC it's
about ninety gigabytes so that should be
okay but for some reason it really can't
handle the park at the moment as you can
see now even though the Main Street is
finished there's not really a way in
which I can really work on the park ins
and with it being in a state like this
with way too many police and causing my
computer to kind of almost cry
I've had one crash actually so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to just see how
if I and how I can fix this leg and then
just try to come up with some ways to
you still keep this Park and expand it
but not have to deal with all this
massive amount like by for example
making buildings and coasters and other
Park files and importing them just in
the end and then make a video of that
because in a video the like doesn't
really matter because I use the in-game
recording but right now that's it for
this episode I'll see you again next
episode hopefully in which I'll make the
ferris wheel and I might make a bnm
coaster like a flyer or a dive machine
but nothing certain when it comes to
that yeah
you